تجري الاختبارات الأولى الأمريكية
للقاح محتمل لفيروس كورونا ، وتجري المرحلة الأولى من
التجربة في ولاية واشنطن ،
وهي واحدة من أكثر المناطق تضررًا في
البلاد ، وقد توفي 50 شخصًا هناك ، دعني
أوضح أن هذه التجربة تطوعية
تمامًا وستستمر لمدة ستة أسابيع 45  يُطلب من
الأفراد الأصحاء الذين تتراوح أعمارهم بين 18 و
55 عامًا المشاركة في
نيل براوننج ، هو واحد منهم
من أوائل المتطوعين الذين
تلقوا هذا اللقاح
التجريبي بالفعل.  لذلك كان هذا
تطوعيًا تمامًا ، فأنت بصحة جيدة ، فلماذا
كنت ترغب في القيام بذلك لتحقيق هذه الغاية في
أسرع وقت ممكن لبقية
العالم إذا كنت بصحة جيدة بما يكفي لأتمكن
من المساهمة في البحث وآمل أن
تجد لقاحًا في وقت أقرب من  لاحقًا
لماذا لا أشكرك على ذلك ،
هل يمكنك فقط شرح عدد جولات
الحقن التي ستحصل عليها وهل قال الطبيب
ما هي الآثار الجانبية التي كان من الممكن أن
تحدثها معي حول المحادثة التي
أجريتها معك  طبيبك متأكد ، لذا فإن
الخطوة الأولى كانت التأكد من أن الجميع
يتمتعون بصحة جيدة ، لذلك خضع الجميع
لاختبارات سحب الدم للتأكد من
أن كل شيء يبدو جيدًا بعد
أن تم إعطاؤنا اللقاح ، وعلينا
عمل مخطط يومي حيث نقوم
بقياس درجة حرارتنا وتدوين أي منها  الآثار الجانبية أو
الأشياء التي قد نراها والتي يمكن أن تكون
عاملاً مساهماً من اللقاح
مرة واحدة في الأسبوع ، نحتاج إلى العودة
وسحب الدم حيث سينتقلون
خلال فحص الدم للتأكد من
أن الجسم يتفاعل بالطريقة
المتوقعة  إنتاج المستضدات التي
نأمل أن تسمح لنا بمكافحة
الفيروس التاجي إذا تعرضنا
له
في نهاية الأسبوع الرابع أعود بالفعل
وسيحصل الجميع على جرعة ثانية
من اللقاح نمر بها خلال
فترة أربعة أسابيع أخرى من مرة واحدة في الأسبوع
للعودة  الدم ويتتبعون كيفية
تقدم ذلك من هناك
كيف سيعرف الأطباء ما إذا كان هذا يعمل أم
لا ، والطريقة التي يعمل بها هذا لا
يوجد فيروس حقيقي في هذا اللقاح ولا
واحد تم إضعافه ولا ميت ،
يستخدمون
تقنية جديدة تعلم
الخلايا في جسدي أساسًا لبناء
هياكل بروتينية تشبه الغلاف
الخارجي لفيروس كورونا الفعلي ، يجب أن
يتفاعل جسدي مع ذلك وأن يراه على أنه
غازي أجنبي يهاجمه و  تعلم كيفية
محاربة هذا الهيكل الذي
بناه جسدي على
افتراض أن الأعمال يجب أن تكون قادرة
على تتبع وجود مستضدات
وخلايا دم بيضاء يتم إنتاجها
لرقمين يظهران استجابة أمينية
كما هو متوقع
حسنًا ، دعنا نتحدث عن الأطفال
والآباء  قضاء
وقت ممتع في المنزل الآن مع
الصغار ، لكن هذا خاصة مع الأطفال أو
الصغار ، قد تكون
نصيحتك مرعبة للغاية وهذا مهم قبل
التعامل مع مخاوفهم
ومخاوفهم تدير مشاعرك أولاً ، لذا
اشرح  لماذا هذا مهم جدًا لأن
الأطفال لديهم شريان حياة عاطفي
لوالديهم ونتيجة لذلك فهم
إسفنج صغير ولا يمتصونه
بغض النظر عما تقوله ،
فإنهم يمتصون ما تشعر به ، لذا فإن
أفضل طريقة للمساعدة في تهدئة الطفل هي تهدئة
نفسك سواء كان ذلك تأملًا يقظًا
سواء كانت بعض
الحيل السلوكية المعرفية لإعادة صياغة هذا
كمرحلة جديدة إيجابية ومثيرة للاهتمام في الحياة
ثم أنت  يمكن أن تصل إلى العمل الجيد المتمثل في
شرح ما يجري في داخلك للأطفال ،
تعرف لغة بسيطة وليست لغة مخيفة ،
لكن أليست هذه تجربة علمية مثيرة للاهتمام
تحدث بشكل جيد ،
والأطفال أذكياء فهم يعرفون أن شخصًا ما
يدور حولك وأنت
لا تعرفه  تعرف عندما لا يكون شخص ما
صادقًا ، فإن السؤال عما يجب أن يقوله
لأطفالك قد طرح أثناء
إحاطة حول فيروس كورونا في البيت الأبيض
يوم الاثنين ، هذه هي الطريقة التي أجاب بها الرئيس ترامب
على السؤال
الذي تحدثت عنه بالفعل مع ابني ، وهو يقول ما
مدى سوء هذا  إنه أمر سيء ، إنه أمر سيء ،
لكننا سنصل إلى
أفضل الحالات ، وليس أسوأ الحالات
، وهذا ما نعمل لأجله
، أنا آسف على الآباء أن يكونوا ربما
أكثر من ذلك بقليل  تأكد أكثر من
أنك تشرح أشياء مثل
غسل يديك هي طريقة جيدة حقًا
لوقف الفيروس من تمكين
الأطفال بدلاً من مجرد ترويعهم فقط
، أعني أنه يمكننا تهدئة مخاوف الناس من
خلال منحهم إحساسًا بالتحكم
فيما إذا كانوا  طفل أو شخص بالغ ،
فماذا نقول للبالغين يرتدون أقنعة ،
اغسل يديك ، وارتداء القفازات وما إلى ذلك ، ومع
الأطفال يمكننا طمأنتهم
بشيء آخر إلى جانب قضاء الوقت في
تعليمهم عن الجراثيم المجهرية ، يمكننا أيضًا
تعليمهم أن هناك الكثير من
العلماء العاملين  من الصعب جدًا في الوقت الحالي
جعل اللقاح للأطفال
يفهمون اللقاحات التي حصلوا عليها
منذ ولادتهم ، لذا
أوضح لهم أنه
قريبًا جدًا سيقدم بعض العلماء الأذكياء المذهلين
لقاحًا
لنا جميعًا وسنقوم جميعًا  كن آمنًا مرة أخرى وفي
هذه الأثناء نبقى
منفصلين قليلاً عن بعضنا البعض للحفاظ على سلامتنا ،
هذا هو أحد أهم المستشفيات
في العاصمة الإسبانية
يعالجون مرضى فيروس كورونا
لن يخبرونا بعددهم أو ما هي
حالتهم ، والأهم من
ذلك أن هذا المستشفى يشارك في
تجربة سريرية جديدة لعقار تم
استخدامه لبعض عناصر فيروس كورونا
التي يريدونها  لنرى كيف يعمل
ضد فيروس كورونا Cova 19 ، إنه
جهد أوروبي مستشفيات في ألمانيا ،
فرنسا وإيطاليا ، والآن إسبانيا تشارك
في هذه التجربة السريرية وما
سيفعلونه هو أنهم يأخذون المرضى
المتطوعين في فئتين الأكثر
خطورة  المرضى الذين يرغبون في معرفة
ما إذا كان هذا الدواء الجديد يخفض من درجة الحرارة لديهم أم لا
، وبالنسبة للمرضى الأكثر اعتدالًا
، يريدون معرفة ما إذا كان الدواء الجديد
يخرجهم من المستشفى بشكل أسرع ، فإن
هذا المستشفى مثلهم جميعًا في إسبانيا
يخضع الآن للسيطرة المباشرة للحكومة الإسبانية
الأولوية رقم واحد هي
فيروس كورونا ، فهم يتوقعون
تدفقًا إضافيًا لمرضى جودمان
سي إن إن مدريد